an einem tag im jahr der ersten
mondlandung für die stadt zur
buchhandlung meine mutter hatte mir 20
mark gegeben um schon bücher zu kaufen
vorher allerdings wollte ich noch
schnell einen kurzen abstecher in die
spielzeugabteilung des kaufhofs machen
dort gab es eine so genannte astronauten
ausrüstung zu kaufen
die mondlandung namen in meinen gedanken
größten raum ein
bei der astronauten ausrüstung handelte
es sich um eine art peter hammer preis
1990 dessen stoff eine gummierte
silberfarbene beschichtung erhalten
hatte
so beginnt ein kapitel von matthias
franz buch raumpatrouille es ist das
erste mal dass sich der renommierte
schauspieler als autor versucht brand
schildert die magische welt eines
kleinen jungen ungefähr zehn jahre alt
und er gewährt einen einblick in seine
eigene kindheit als sohn von
bundeskanzler willy brandt damals eine
der prominentesten männer der welt
wie war das mit zu einem vater das war
einfach unglaublich auf den reagieren
das ist ja weil es freiheit mein vater
und und man wundert sich dann eher warum
die daher zu verrückt spielen willy
brandts kniefall in warschau seiner
demut geste vor dem denkmal für die
helden des ghettos machte ihn zum
hoffnungsträger
mitten im kalten krieg wollte er
zwischen ost und west vermitteln
willy brandt wird zur symbolfigur
ich kann mir das nicht anders vorstellen
als dass es anstrengend ist auf der
anderen seite glaube ich um eine solche
projektionsfläche zu bieten muss man
auch bereit sein leuten die zu geben
dass also ganz ohne eigenes zutun findet
so was nicht statt das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen
der junge braucht eine gegenwelt zu dem
der erwachsenen in der alles von
höchster wichtigkeit ist fußballer villa
wären fußball war die größte
leidenschaft die ich bisher empfunden
hatte die ganze woche war auf die
trainingszeiten und spiele ausgerichtet
alles prädestinierte mich zum fußballer
außer dass ich nicht gut war der ball
tat nicht was ich wollte und analysiert
seine kindheit sehr genau
erhellend wenn er vor den privilegien
als sohn des berühmten vaters erzählt
vom kirmesbesuch mit den eltern
der sich als presse- und fototermin
entpuppt
wir gehen zu einer losbude ich frage
meine mutter ob ich geld bekommen können
dann wird ein der verkäufer ein großer
geldscheine zugesteckt und der los
einmal aus der hand genommen
ich soll jedes der kleinen lose auf
polen so lange bis ich endlich den
hauptgewinn gezogen habe endlich findet
sich das los mit dem hauptgewinn ein
großer großer teddybär
man mag das ja als kind nicht diese
herausgehoben hyde
das will ja eigentlich das gegenteil man
will ja eher zu den anderen gehören und
wie die anderen sein ich habe das auch
immer mich haben auch immer was ja auch
thematisiert wird in dem buch andere
welten sehr interessiert die anders
waren als die die ich zu hause kennen
gelernt habe trotzdem zieht es matthias
brandt selbst ins rampenlicht
sein durchbruch kommt mit der rolle des
kommissars in der krimiserie polizeiruf
ich weiß wie sich das anfühlt alleine zu
sein
ich will einem internat
die eltern hatten immer viel um die
ohren
august ihr wissen
ob ich habe im fernsehen gesehen als
leibhaftig ein monolog der klingt als
rede er seinen eigenen vater willy
brandt wenn man so eine herausgehobene
figur als vater hat dann ist ja dann ist
es ja so dass man ständig mit leuten zu
tun hat die meinen sie würden ihn kennen
was aber natürlich eine riesen
projektion ist und man muss irgend
welche techniken oder strategien
entwickeln leuten verständlich zu machen
dass die projektion mit der sie herum
laufen nichts zu tun hat mit dem was für
mich mein vater ist matthias brandt
zweck tab auch in seinen geschichten und
wirft so den liebevollen blick eines
sohnes auf dem berühmten vater